you look at it and and you wonder about
the chances they have to win it all and
it's like well if I just went through
this in a day who's to say I can't you
know continue riding that wave and they
put the strongest players with see the
thing is - this is a gathering you know
some of the best players from around not
only the US but around the world
yes this has got to serve as some type
of just level up function for a lot of
these players they are able to not only
play in the tournament setting but you
saw early on all those players the
players downstairs playing those guys
are already out of it it always is this
oh this is it all right into the event
now drinking on try the treat night air
don't obey is gonna come through with to
be as we saw earlier break attacks early
on at 2p or the two key stage yeah
random okay what kind of mix-up we're
gonna get here but right now great the
on in the yellow people control the
space nice using the tip of their of the
six beat trying to play the wall right
now trying to force his way in finally
breaks through opens up free walling day
I got carrots hard activated big chunk
of damage and there is is you might be
able close anyone for the 2k again the
first you don't succeed try again a just
elated elope at this time cuz he knew
that what that flapjack he was gonna
check back no reason not to a 2k would
have been guarantee but in that
situation you send up the later though
PT terror charge and to the follow-up
SIG's be gonna take as much time as you
can't really go him yeah almost have the
wall there to it look old marry walk
Louise gonna get it out of range not
able to land it but the sword is a
little bit longer than yours alright I'm
gonna pull the seniority card here the
franchise night bear with the Smackdown
have to have his work cut out from here
but looking at Raytheon able to get two
rounds there yeah scared me a bit
they're not able to close out of mess
we've seen one too many times throughout
the entirety of this truck that people
fall flat it's over especially with the
ring out potential in this thing
these characters not effective right now
because they are by the walls but both
these carriers have some see what
happens out of here
lift and continue with it but don't
follow up this time gonna slap you down
from the air anti-air slamming that got
the wall as well
Oh any the big boots of the wall again
we're gonna charge it up let's see what
he does all of the the funky little
angles are going in favor of Raytheon
that was just clean yeah we ground
straight very clean over to be or not to
be that case let's go back to the board
alright last time it was no mermaid she
was able to put lava we have prevented
Compaq now he's on the other side yeah
that's the thing you gotta you got a go
big or you got to go home right and look
at it we are in the loser's bracket I
got to remind everyone from here on out
this is the clutch you've got to be able
to pull or you are out your tournament
life is done everybody well not just
that this is the baby bracket but you
have the big one later tonight stop okay
let's focus on what's ahead of us God it
feels so good to watch this the house
man we're calling the shots let's go
starting it off again burst the bubble
I'm just gonna run out first immediately
just check just to show you what's going
on these are the rules in this house
waiting for any interruption just
outside of the racing for the big boy
wants a tracheostomy overly aggressive
and uh about oh my gosh over the fence
about that well as you see the fence is
like kind of bent yeah that's the kind
of fence we to jump you know we were
young we want to play basketball on this
court but it's close the fence is a bad
high and just get rid of it make your
way in finding the opening again this
time nice able to use the bubble when he
needs it yeah denial not gonna deal with
it in this situation now yeah and
company's going a little bit lighter
want to fix up not going too deep single
hit two three there oh yeah busy that's
the thing with my America's explosive
nature if he gets the wall and in the
right timing he could put on the hurt
here in this matchup here we go gets the
follow up and he's gonna charge up let's
go now having to deal with a bit more of
nightmares resources all right break
delay this time knowing bass not being
is trying to match tricky on aggressive
label because you can't how about a side
step into wind punish you know fasted
waiting close it out there alright cool
you know guts position more damage but
they the audience and I can't tell you
how many times we've seen this kind of
situation today you know the first
player will go up in a nice lead three
straight rounds and then the other
player makes a similar push where their
schooling captain's that get around
right now Nova made threatening here to
take a few rounds here and tying it up
yeah there seems to be a great sense of
urgency that's just in the air tonight
the way I don't even think it's the
players like it's just floating around
and then they breathe it and it's like
okay it's time to figure it out to get
more the same see a slap you back free
ante on the counter here at the air
attack adjusts no denial flyswatter
alright you say on the ground we don't
want anything to do with you I heard a
buzz where is he when i'm tom perski
necessary charge hurt oh my god damn
it's how was that fair the full
extension baby just outside of raid zero
chin all right watch your legs too sweet
great denial at this time mercy before
you can get it poppin yeah yeah they
cover his ground there but great jobs
now Nova major pushing towards other
side playing a very very smart interest
rate Dion oh my god and that's gonna is
that gonna punish no outside of range
here very unfortunate situation Tara
charge active talk to me now looking for
the fix up no throw crap yeah yes decide
with the pressure inside step here we go
let's see what happens oh and the big
sweep there and Nova made able to tie it
up look at that one piece now
[Music]
run away the same way ran away from
soaring stay back and do my thing from
the distance I know a really great job
adjusting from the prior match so now
we're going to the final then you solve
it not just okay I got this quickly
dance
alright now it's close
let's try to figure this out as we get
things popping into a final game drama
it's gonna be the theme of this event
all right Kohl's walls don't ring outs
oh nice you could take you the sky's not
on my watch
all right here pushing again that's
right so aggressive will something and
even though it's it will punish their
it's is gonna press again but continue
the string keep it going because why not
right if it hits you can pick it back up
right now it's nobody's just trying to
pick up single launches at a time here's
a throw taking damage any in every which
way trying to fight back you're able to
get the bump Leggett's go although up
this is looking good nice block might be
it oh oh there it is no image taking the
lead now in the set after being down
that was a very like anti-climatic
ground it just kind of you know like I
want this but nothing too excited no
data don't download something there just
straight up by the books clocks in did
his work got out of there with the W
alright a couple punches in follow up
got out of the sea II having none of it
and no movies right now in favorable
position but right now notice ya ending
everything in standing resets so sick
right now but again nightmares so much
damage it's so much first punish with a
very big V they're able to get the
critical edge and look at that up now
two rounds here in this final match
straight the oddly this is all you got
to do it you got to put it on the line
yeah seemingly a little bit of overkill
that but what do you have a you know
move that fast guarantee it you don't
drop it you don't mess up the situation
always spend the cash this is your the
round
see I speak you spending the cash so
charge he wasn't building anymore meters
so here we go let's see how it ends up
for a bow this is a whip punish Britta
glitch very ineffective sole charge
therefore entry fee on unfortunately as
Nova Paige takes advantage with punish
big damage and tax on the CEO on top of
that you wouldn't think he was the one
who sold charge looking for the follow
ups trying to keep the pressure again
pushing toward the wall has to use it
this might be his last stand
Oh knocked out of the air very fortunate
situation I couldn't see what happened
until it was over there in the end
rave blocks on the mix-up it's a kind of
tag fighting back to Theon not laying
down just yet working on that cars case
slaps him down oh he gets in stay alive
a breath of fresh air for drapion who
just felt depth creeping up on his
tournament run refused to go out like
that
he's gonna have to kind of strategize
how we did it because he knows if he is
able to tie it up he's gonna give it
over mage the meter here so there goes
the purse again let's see what he does
knocks you out of the air he's making a
lot of those six fees to hit in the
aerial state but unable to convert to
even more damage going the other way
doing so much doubt the Swift kicks up
top and tricky on in the driver's seat
now trying to force this oh my gosh just
whittling away at the light bar and look
at that the little tap able to take your
final round this man was on the edge of
defeat yet the pull like a 90% comeback
and now it is his game to play soul
charge flipped over beige plastic yellow
bar a bit of aggression right back at
you yeah fighting fire with fire they're
both charged up let's see which player
is gonna get the big hints here that and
make them count with this whole charge
that the fraction of its own at Raytheon
working on that dark cage Fred active
Nova base trying to force the offense
and caught him pressing a button
sport go to maneuver right there after
assessing the situation in the air in so
little frames oh yeah it's dopamine it's
gonna buy him some time for sure but
again still in the danger zone he's
gonna have to be very very careful I
look at that his life are just depleted
I know that should be enough to get the
job done right the odd from the
clutches of defeat keeping in
tournaments life online
pants sake cheese slice smile and you
can't believe him cold and calculated
back-to-back able to squeak it out I
like it I like it he's gonna stay alive
and be able to fight throughout again
the topic of lose sight he's gonna win
if he keeps playing with our hearts like
that Raytheon slowly becoming the hero
of this event one by one but again
that's just to get into topic he's now
on the Luthor side still has another
seven individuals he has to get through
and to close out that topic one last
qualifier is gonna be Omega D are going
up oh sorry